[Music]  my son sacrificed his life to save me  [Music]  these powers  are not a gift  but a curse  born  out of rage  [Music]  this loose cannon needs to be locked  down  before innocent people start getting  hurt  he's been asleep for five thousand years  if you find us a cell that can hold him  we'll take care of the rest who's on the  team  i didn't bring a passport you don't need  passports  we're the justice society  black adam we're here to negotiate your  peaceful surrender  i'm not peaceful  nor do i surrender  here we go  i kneel before no one  [Music]  you didn't come here to seek justice  you came to exact revenge  [Music]  i never said i was a hero  [Music]  you believe you are not worthy  but fate does not make mistakes  [Music]  you have two paths  you can be the destroyer of this world  or you can be its savior  you